[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans votre 7,8
l'hebdo au sommaire ce vendredi 26 juin
le célèbre parcours de 1000 maquette
france miniature rouvrait ses portes ce
vendredi
nous ferons le point sur les conditions
de visite et l'affluence au premier jour
après pratiquement trois mois d'arrêt la
vie culturelle et sportive reprend petit
à petit à saint quentin en yvelines
nous verrons plusieurs exemples
d'infrastructures qui ont rouvert leurs
portes dans cette édition et nous en
discuterons avec l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines
reprise de l'école pour tout le monde
les cinémas qui accueille à nouveau du
public et inauguration de la maison de
santé de plaisir nous reviendrons sur ce
qui a marqué l'actualité cette semaine
dans les yvelines ce vendredi matin se
tenait le conseil départemental des
yvelines largement consacrée à la
solidarité territoriale un budget de 15
millions d'euros a été votée pour
soutenir les communes qui souhaitent et
des commerçants et artisans locaux dans
leurs échéances immobilière plus de 5000
150 établissements sont éligibles au
dispositif
les candidatures sont ouvertes jusqu'au
31 août
côté santé une prime va être versée aux
salariés des établissements et services
sociaux et médico-sociaux mobilisés
depuis le début de l'épidémie ne
coronavirus la participation du
département dans cette prime s'élève à
près de 2 millions d'euros
enfin le pass plus yvelines hauts de
seine qui permettait aux collégiens de
bénéficier d'un porte monnaie
électronique d'au moins 80 euros à
utiliser auprès d'associations ou
d'organismes sportifs et culturels a été
étendu aux jeunes de 15 à 18 ans une
façon également de soutenir le secteur
associatif ce sont plus de 300 mille
jeunes qui devraient en bénéficier
le site aurait dû rouvrir le 4 avril
mais l'épidémie deux copies de 19 en a
décidé autrement
les 117 monuments de france miniature
non patienter pendant trois mois avant
d'acquérir de nouveaux leur public c'est
chose faite ce vendredi mélanie poké
hématies de déminer une visite quasiment
privé pour la première matinée
d'ouverture de france miniature une
centaine de personnes est venue
découvrir les grands monuments français
sa part qu'on affectionne
particulièrement on adore se promener
ici et comme bien peu de monde
finalement on n'a même pas besoin
d'avoir le masque parce qu'on peut très
bien se promener tranquillement sans
rencontrer grand monde
ça se passe très très bien si l'un de
mes parents
préférez c'est vraiment génial il ya des
petits traits partout c'est super les
enfants sont contents
on peut multiplier se balader comme on
veut y'a pas de problème d distanciation
on respire un peu on va dire les enfants
en fait il avait très envie de venir on
avait prévu d'y aller pour
l'anniversaire du grand qui était le 30
mars mais du coup comme c'était fermé
voilà donc dès leur ouverture on a dit
on y va on en met les garçons et puis
c'est très content de ce que c'était une
surprise
la reprise s'est donc fait tout en
douceur pour l'équipe du site élan
courtois les monuments n'avait pas vu
deux publics depuis le mois de novembre
c'était aussi une volonté d'ouvrir à
vendredi pour commencer sereinement et
doucement et dès ce week end je pense
qu'on va accueillir un petit peu plus de
monde on a quelques réservations en
ligne
et puis notre communication vient d'être
lancée également jusqu'à la veille jeudi
25 juin les salariés peaufiner les
derniers réglages sur le pont depuis la
mi mai ils ont pris soin de la demeure
du roi soleil
alors il restait pas mal de choses
notamment sur versa il à la fin de la
restauration c'est une maquette qu'on
restaure en plusieurs fois tel total est
grande
il ya à peu près 200 m² de maquettes sur
le parc donc on a fait en trois fois en
mars dernier l'élan de france miniature
est stoppé net par le confinement
décidées par l'état à deux semaines
d'une réouverture annuel et 15 salariés
permanents sont placés en chômage
partiel et les grilles restent closes
c'est évidemment très très impactant
pour france miniature qui accueille
chaque année deux cent mille visiteurs
et ça depuis trois ans on avait belle
remontée de la fréquentation depuis ces
trois dernières années compte tenu de
toutes les nouveautés qu'on avait
installé quatre familiale enfin qui
répondait aux attentes de notre public
et ils sont ces trois mois d'ouverture
et de nos ouvertures plus exactement on
a perdu près de cent mille de nos
visiteurs attendus accès visiteurs et
files d'attentes repenser salariés
supplémentaires pour veiller au bon
respect des consignes ou encore espace
fermé non accessibles france miniature
est ouvert tous les jours de l'été un
tour de l'hexagone en une seule journée
[Musique]
et ce sont globalement toutes nos
actualités de loisirs qui reprennent
petit à petit le culturel mais aussi
sportifs
mélanie poké fait le point avec geoffroy
greffe directeur adjoint à la proximité
de saint quentin en yvelines
geoffroy greffe bonjour après quasiment
trois mois d'arrêt le monde de la
culture du sport et des loisirs reprend
de l'activité le 17 juin à dernier le
musée de la ville et les médiathèques
rouvert mais elles ont modifié leurs
offres
oui effectivement la vie reprend à saint
quentin pour le plus grand bonheur des
saint quentinois mais aussi de
l'ensemble des collaborateurs des
directions culture sport qui sont
mobilisés nous avons effectivement
repris de manière phase est tout d'abord
au niveau du réseau des médiathèques
nous avons ouvert depuis la mi juin sous
forme de drive nous avons cinq
médiathèque qui aujourd'hui proposent
aux saint quentinois de pouvoir à
nouveau accéder au prêt par le biais de
drive et à partir du 7 juillet je crois
qu'il ya beaucoup beaucoup d'impatience
mais on comprend les saint quentinois
ils pourront à nouveau retrouvée en
déambulation est rentré dans les
médiathèques retrouver à nouveau
l'ensemble des services côté sport aussi
ça à peu repris au vélodrome reçoit de
nouveau des cyclistes avec le stadium
bmx normale notamment
oui effectivement le vélodrome après une
longue période également d'hibernation
dioko vide reprend son activité avec
l'ensemble bien sûr des mesures
barrières qui sont toujours mises en
avant mais effectivement les activités
au niveau de la fédération française de
cyclisme ont repris le bmx le cyclisme
sur piste et notre partenaire lui cpa
qui gère la partie événementielle a
également travaillé sur un programme
d'animations estivales
et est-ce que du côté des associations
vous avez pu échanger pour repartir du
bon pied
oui nous avons pendant toute cette
période
continuer à préserver le lien avec les
associations notamment les associations
du secteur social
qui étaient très mobilisées pendant
cette période auprès auprès des saint
quentinois en difficulté mais aussi
toutes ces associations qui avaient
l'habitude de rendre des services de
créer justement ce lien social
indispensable à notre vie et qui ont été
privés de ces moments des changes
nous avons effectivement garder des
contacts nous les avons rassurés sur un
plan financier toutes les subventions
qui avait été votée en décembre seront
maintenus voilà donc pas de soucis
particuliers et on est toujours très
attentif à leur évolution à la sortie du
collège
en tout cas dès lors que l'on peut les
mobiliser pour leur proposer
d'intervenir dans le cadre des
animations estivales ont fait je pense
que c'est important aussi que la
collectivité soit derrière ces
associations c'est une reprise en
douceur phase et comme vous dites qu'ils
annoncent un été encore plus animé sur
l'agglomération
du côté du musée de la ville il ya des
idées sorties il ya des chasses aux
trésors ya des balades connectés oui oui
effectivement je crois qu'il était
important pour cet été de prévoir une
programmation estivale variés ouverte au
plus grand nombre
on sait qu'un certain nombre de saint
quentinois n'auront pas la possibilité
de pouvoir partir en vacances
on ne voulait pas qu'il soit privé
d'animation sur le territoire donc le
musée de la ville bien entendu se
mobilisent pour comme vous disiez
proposer des balades des des chasses aux
trésors des rallyes l'objectif en tout
cas c'est de permettre aux saint
quentinois de redécouvrir leur
patrimoine naturel historique mais aussi
tout leur public qui se trouvent sur le
territoire
voilà on a beaucoup de choses à
découvrir au pied de chez soi c'était
l'intérêt en tout cas de remettre en
avant ce que souvent on ne on ne voit
plus et la commanderie n'est pas en
reste de ce côté là c'est dès le 6
juillet beaucoup d'activités sont
proposées peut pas fait dès le 6 juillet
nous avons voulu là aussi offrir à
travers le programme c'est les vacances
des stages
r aux jeunes de 6 à 17 ans qui seront
dirigés par des professionnels pour
découvrir notamment la danse les arts
visuels les sciences mais aussi les
écritures contemporaines tout au long du
mois de juillet sur quatre semaines nous
aurons des ateliers permettant
d'accueillir de 10 à 15 aux jeunes pour
leur faire découvrir ses différentes
facettes de la danse des écritures
contemporaines mais aussi des ateliers
autour de la baie des ha du hip hop de
la danse contemporaine
c'est là c'est plutôt culture loisirs
pour ceux qui ont envie de se tester au
sport plutôt du côté de lille de loisirs
oui tout à fait alors sur le loisir
n'oublions pas quand même qu'à la
commanderie nous allons proposer dès le
9 juillet tous les jeudis soir nous
aurons un rendez vous à ne pas manquer à
22h à la commanderie
plus précisément au niveau de la coulée
verte le cinéma plein air et je donne
rendez vous à tous les saint quentinois
donc dès le 9 juillet dès le jeudi soir
pour la première projection ici on a
voulu justement retrouver un petit peu
nos nos classiques
voilà activités en famille l'île de
loisirs bien entendu propose aussi à
travers diverses activités
la possibilité de re découvrir le sport
les loisirs
oublions pas que du quinze du 14 juillet
au 15 août
nous aurons un village sportif et
culturel qui est proposée par la région
ile de france mais nous aurons aussi des
ateliers autour de théâtre des ateliers
autour de partir en libre autour de la
bd jeunesse sans oublier l'ensemble des
activités proposées par l'île de loisirs
l'équitation le golf l'accrobranche la
voile voile à diverses activités qui
seront à en accessibilité pour les
véhicules de manière gratuite puisque
nous avons voulu là aussi permettre à
l'ensemble des franciliens de pouvoir
accéder aux îles de loisirs en ile de
france et en particulier à celles de
saint quentin donc gratuite et pour
l'accès vécu et bien sûr on retrouve
toutes ces animations sur les différents
sites de l'agglomération notamment
qu'est-ce qu'on skie point fr merci
geoffroy greffe je le rappelle vous êtes
directeur adjoint à la proximité à saint
quentin en yvelines
[Musique]
lundi c'était le retour quasi à la
normale dans les écoles et les collèges
yvelinois tous les élèves pouvaient
retourner en cours avec un protocole
sanitaire allégé exemple à l'école
élémentaire romain rolland à saint cyr
l'école avec aurélie rose et grégory
canada après trois semaines d'école à la
maison pour certains tous les élèves ont
pu retrouver leurs salles de classe
depuis le déconfinement en raison d'un
protocole sanitaires strictes seuls 200
écoliers sur les 366 inscrits fréquenté
chaque semaine l'école romain rolland de
saint cyr l'école
désormais tout le monde peut être
accueillis en continuant malgré tout à
respecter quelques gestes barrières
chaque classe a un espace pour prendre
les récréations dans les classes on a
rajouté des tables comme on n'a plus
pour pouvoir garder un maximum de
distance entre les élèves
ça n'a pas toujours été possible donc il
n'ya pas toujours un mètres d'écart
entre chaque élève point ils sont assis
dans la classe il se lave toujours les
mains en rentrant en classe en sortant
récréation en rentrant de récréation
avant de manger à la cantine
toutes les écoles élémentaires de
censure d'école proposent un service de
restauration le midi ainsi que le centre
de loisirs le soir une organisation
rendue possible grâce à la municipalité
la commune fournit jallet
hydroalcoolique savons antibactériens
logique sur les toilettes et et puis
tous les aménagements nécessaires qu'ils
sont
et les traçages au sol dans la cour dans
les couloirs de façon à pouvoir
permettre la distanciation ce matin
cette classe de cm2 comptait seulement
un absent alors que les grandes vacances
débutent dans moins de deux semaines
l'éducation nationale met en avant
plusieurs intérêts pédagogiques pour
cette reprise pour tous symboliquement
psychologiquement c'était important à la
fois de reprendre cette dynamique
globale on va dire normal de d'une
pédagogie de classe entière et puis de
marquer cette transition finalement avec
avant l'été pour pouvoir s'imaginer se
projeter déjà dans la classe du niveau
supérieur l'année prochaine je pense
qu'il faut apprendre à vivre avec les
avec le co vide comme plein d'autres
maladies qui circulent plein d'autres
virus dans 7 établissements scolaires
près de 90 % des élèves sont retournés
en classe 22 juin ils ce sont plus de
200 mille élèves répartis dans les 1000
écoles élémentaires et les 116 collège
des yvelines qui ont pu effectuer leur
retour en classe dès lundi et ce même
jour les cinémas pouvait de nouveau
accueillir leur public nous vous avons
demandé si cela vous avez manqué qu'est
ce que j'ai envie d'aller au cinéma
tout simplement parce que je suis nul je
suis une signifie jeu et donc j'avais
envie de revenir j'en ai je veux dire gg
j'ai confinés comme tout le monde
quelque part savoir que début d'une vie
à peu près normale
voilà mais bon on est content que la vie
reprenne en fait un hasard aujourd'hui
j'avais envie de venir au cinéma donc
j'ai suivi ça m'a manqué moi le grand
écran je viens souvent au cinéma je
viens plusieurs fois par semaine en
principe il ya toute l'ambiance mon nom
n'était pas très nombreux dans la salle
mais pour certains films il ya aussi
l'ambiance qui fait qu'en toute la salle
vibre avec des émotions c'est très
important pour moi j'ai besoin de
gestion d'une ressource et en allant
voir dessiner j'ai besoin de découvrir
des films c'est un divertissement
je suis abonné je suis j'habite à
plaisir je suis abonné à ce cinéma
depuis un certain temps et est quand
j'ai su que ça allait ouvrir ta b
j'étais parmi les trois premiers j'étais
la première à arriver dans la salle
parce que je souhaitais vivement voir ce
film et puis sortie redécouvrir le
cinéma
bien que l'épidémie soit en recul le
respect des gestes-barrières reste la
meilleure solution pour contrer le virus
notamment porter un masque qui reste
vivement recommandée dans l'espace
public à saint-cyr-l'ecole la
municipalité a mis en place la mascc
mobile une camionnette sillonnent les
quartiers de la ville pour remettre des
masques aux habitants mardi la
distribution se dérouler rue gérard
philipe lucien camper et pierre courtade
environ 100 masques sont remis à chaque
tournée pour un total de 3000 protection
distribués pour cette opération les
propos recueillis par matic 2011 charge
des masques dont on tourne une demi
heure dans le quartier ensuite on se
pose à un point
les gens viennent donc soit ils sont
déjà inscrits sur l'application soit ils
ne sont pas et on le fait directement
qu'il faut venir avec des documents et
on leur donne normale à metz pour
chercher des masques pour se protéger et
protéger des hôtes
on est trois grandes personnes plus de
deux ans à la maison les utilisent pour
le des transports quand on se retrouve
tout seul au magasin y la crise
sanitaire que nous venons de traverser
peux montre l'enjeu que peut avoir le
rapprochement entre médecine de ville et
hôpital la maison santé peut apporter
une bonne solution peut être à cette
problématique c'est le cas à plaisir
avec la ruche que la présidente de
région ile-de-france valérie pécresse a
visité la semaine dernière les images de
nicolas landry provisoirement situé dans
les locaux de l'hôpital de plaisir le
temps de la construction d'une maison de
santé tout neuf sur le terrain voisin la
ruche a ouvert ses portes en février et
accueille déjà quatre praticiens
paramédicaux ce que très important ici à
plaisir c'est d'avoir à dos et la maison
de santé à l'hôpital de plaisir c'est
donc de permettre à toutes les personnes
qui sont malades d'avoir un trait
d'union entre l'hôpital et la ville
à peine ouvert qu la maison
pluridisciplinaire de santé a dû fermer
pendant le confinement
les praticiens commence donc doucement à
prendre leurs marques et se montre
motivé par ce projet la difficulté en
libéral c'est d'être isolé et d'être
seul donc l'intérêt d'être dans une
équipe pluridisciplinaire ces deux
d'échanger avec des collègues de créer
des projets c4 paramédicaux se sont déjà
installés le plus difficile reste de
trouver les médecins généralistes qui
intégreront la maison de santé
définitive cette infirmière libérale
originaire de plaisir est de la ville à
convaincre de jeunes médecins de
s'installer dans la commune pour qu'on
en a un qui est sûr d'intégrer la maison
de santé définitive donc début 2023 nous
l'espérons est normalement c'est presque
fait mais nous en cherchons deux autres
donc je continue avec mes collègues à
séduire à parler de notre maison de
santé parmi les objectifs de la ruche
pouvoir proposer des créneaux d'urgence
sans rendez vous le bâti
2 600 m² financé par le département
devraient être livrés d'ici 2023
la ville de plaisir en assurera la
gestion les médiathèques de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines aussi ont
doucement repris leurs activités pour
permettre à leurs abonnés de lire selon
leurs envies certains sites proposent
des drive exemple mercredi à la
médiathèque du canal
installé à montigny le bretonneux avec
mélanie poké les cent vingt mille
documents de la médiathèque du canal ont
retrouvé leurs lecteurs depuis le 17
juin le public est de retour
mais pour limiter les contacts les
équipes se sont mises au drive comme de
nombreux sites l'organisation a été
repensé par la trentaine de salariés
toute l'équipe est sur le pont pour
rechercher les réservations fairly près
gérer les retours via la boîte de retour
la mise en quarantaine des documents
voilà il ya toute une logistique
derrière la prise de rendez vous on a
mis en place un accueil téléphonique
avec des mines supplémentaires pour
répondre à un maximum
aux questions et aux demandes pour
renforcer les consignes sanitaires les
équipes mettent de côté les ouvrages
pendant trois jours selon les
recommandations du ministère
réservations sur internet est prise deux
créneaux horaires en deux jours la
médiathèque a reçu plus de 1000
commandes
on est un peu déçu que ce soit que cinq
livres par réservation ce que moi j'ai
un petit garçon qui lit très vite et on
aimerait bien pouvoir réserver un peu
plus mais bah sinon c'est quand même
mieux que rien et on vient le mercredi
et le samedi pour pouvoir avoir assez de
lits variés contente de retrouver toute
l'équipe
voilà que pouvoir pouvoir lire aussi
pour cet été ça tombe très très bien
j'utilisais beaucoup en fait toutes les
semaines je prenais je rendais avec les
enfants c'était pratique et la bombe à
ça on emprunte peut-être moins mai
on emprunte 5 médiathèque propose
actuellement un drive elles sont
complétées par le bibliobus deux autres
accepte seulement les retours avant de
proposer des services plus élargie à
partir du 7 juillet après les écoles les
cinémas la médiathèque faisons un tour
du côté de la réouverture des
infrastructures sportives
le centre aquatique du lac de montigny
le bretonneux a décidé de rouvrir à
partir du 25 juin pour mieux se préparer
à accueillir les nageurs un protocole
strict pour éviter au maximum les
contacts entre sportifs
mathilde et demi s'est plongé dans
l'ambiance il n'y aura que 100 places
disponibles dans les bassins pour des
créneaux de deux heures le centre
aquatique du lac a revu toute son
organisation et à installer un protocole
strict pour l'entrée nous mettons à
disposition cette zone là de cabine
on voit au sol le marquage pour
respecter la distance le cabinet après
avoir désinfecté la cabine qui viendra
d'être utilisés permettra au nouvel
usager d'y accéder la personne ce genre
on la retrouve de l'autre côté pour
accueillir les nageurs des cabinets ont
été mis à disposition pour les guider
jusqu'au vestiaire
une fois changé ils sont ensuite emmenés
jusqu'aux douche et au bassin
les gens qui pourront venir devront au
préalable s'inscrire donc nous avons dû
aussi mettre en place sur le site
internet
le gris d'inscription qui leur permet de
devenir
et puis nous avons privilégié évidemment
le
le passage des personnes de montigny et
de voisins qui sont les deux co
propriétaire de l'établissement pour une
ligne d'eau il faudra compter six
nageurs maximum le bonnet de bain qui
est obligatoire doit être
systématiquement plonger dans du
désinfectant avant d'être utilisées et
les serviettes doivent être placés dans
les gradins à des endroits précis de
tout temps même en dehors de l'aco vide
l'eau est désinfectée ni désinfectante
nous avons fait le choix de que ce soit
par le chlore est donc en l'occurrence à
aujourd'hui il n'y a aucune étude qui
pourrait démontrer qu'il y aurait des
risques potentiels à pratiquer la
natation dans un espace aquatique et
ludique comme celui ci la piscine
accueillera donc jeudi 25 juin les
nageurs
quant aux salles de fitness et de
musculation de l'espace forme du centre
elles rouvriront à partir du lundi 29
juin les vacances scolaires arrivent et
les jeunes s'activent pour leur
recherche de jobs d'été avec la crise
sanitaire l'offre se fait rare les
secteurs de la restauration l'hôtellerie
et le tourisme qui jouent un rôle
crucial chez les saisonniers ont été
fortement impactés il une information
jeunesse et le pôle jeunesse de montigny
le bretonneux accompagnent les jeunes
dans leurs recherches aux ces temps
difficiles mathilde de 2000
depuis sa réouverture le pôle jeunesse
de montigny le bretonneux accueille
trois jeunes pour les aider dans leur
recherche de jobs d'été pour ce jeune de
16 ans il faudra d'abord mettre à jour
son cv pour ensuite postuler pour mettre
plutôt l'objet de ta recherche parce que
le recruteur il veut savoir si tu
cherches un emploi ou juste un job et
étudiant le monde agricole le service à
la personne l'hôtellerie le tourisme ou
encore la restauration sont des secteurs
qui recrutent beaucoup de saisonniers
cette année ces secteurs ont été très
impacté par la crise sanitaire et les
offres pour un job d'été se font rares
je pense ça va être beaucoup plus dur
parce que pour les commerçants les
entreprises
la conjoncture est assez incertaine déjà
ils n'ont pas beaucoup de visibilité si
ça va reprendre l'activité va reprendre
à la normale et même s'ils vont pouvoir
garder leurs salariés par la suite donc
les besoins saisonniers seront plus
restreint après ils peuvent avoir au
bout d'un certain temps avec un surcroît
d'activité besoin de personnel
occasionnel dans les bureaux doublé
d'information jeunesse tout se passe à
présent sur les réseaux sociaux pour
s'adapter à la situation des années
précédentes le mois de mai était décisif
pour trouver une offre d'emploi cette
année les offres arrivent au compte
gouttes
on a toujours travaillé sur des forums
avec du dating c'est à dire des
entreprises et les jeunes depuis de
nombreuses années on avait déjà commencé
à enclencher des réunions de travail
qu'on a dû annuler puisque les forums
n'ont pas eu lieu
on a voulu éventuellement leur est
organisé en juin juillet mais en fait on
n'avait pas de retour des entreprises
donc les entreprises sont en train de
reprendre leurs actes leurs activités
mais n'ont pas tellement de visibilité
donc en fait aujourd'hui au vu du
contexte c'est maintenant que ça se
passe en fait et c'est un petit peu au
jour le jour l'année 2020 s'annonce plus
compliquée pour la recherche d'un emploi
saisonnier
il faudra patienter et rechercher
activement sur les sites plateforme et
réseaux sociaux pour espérer trouver un
job cet été et on arrive à la fin de
cette édition merci de nous avoir suivis
dimanche n'oubliez pas notre soirée
spéciale second tour des élections
municipales nous serons en direct dès
19h45 pour vous faire vivre ces
résultats en temps réel avec les
diverses réactions des candidats et
l'inde et le 7 une journal revient
largement sur ces élections pour ikken
sur tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour m
[Musique]